justement va s'intéresser aux élections
régionales chez nous avec vous l'avez
dit bruno cette surprise socialiste le
président sortant françois bonneau qui
déjoue les sondages en arrivant devant
le rassemblement national d'aleksandar
nico leach suivi de la droite de nicolas
forissier en quatrième position le
ministre loir et chérien un marc fesneau
et surprise ce soir le candidat de la
majorité présidentielle ne fusionne pas
et maintiendrait sa liste au second tour
ont fait le point avec aurélie renault
avec des taux de participation normaux
on peut aller chercher cette région face
aux caméras celui que les sondages
annoncé comme le grand vainqueur du 1er
tour accuse le coup le jeune candidat
est reine aleksandar nikolic ne
fusionnera pas il ira chercher ses
réserves de voix chez les
abstentionnistes
quand vous avez 70 % d'abstention les
réserves de voile c'est mathieu donc
dans l'abstention
la faute évidemment je veux dire bien
sûr c'est finalement françois bonneau
qui crée la surprise sa liste remporte
24% des suffrages sur notre plateau le
président sortant à l'appel à la
mobilisation car la situation reste
tendue pour que le rassemblement
national n'a aucune possibilité de
prendre cette région dès ce soir
ce qui compte véritablement c'est la
mobilisation leur rassemblement tout
d'abord et je vais tout faire pour le
concrétiser avec la mairie que europe
écologie les verts fusion concrétiser ce
lundi avec la liste de charles fournier
europe ecologie les verts et la france
insoumise qui obtenait hier soir 10 %
des suffrages
j'ajoute qu'une liste dissidente à fait
hors aides pour cent et que elle parle
aussi d'écologie elle a placé aussi
l'écologie au coeur de son ponton oui si
on additionne on est plutôt du côté de
15% donc on pèse dans cette élection de
manière importante
hier le candidat ait l'air lui était
heureux nicolas forissier que les
sondages placent est en quatrième
position arrive troisième avec 18,8 pour
cent des voix devant le candidat de la
majorité présidentielle marc fesneau
j'ai pas été appelée par monsieur feno
jusqu'à présent on verra bien ce qui se
passera mais en tout état de cause je
souhaite tracer la route que j'ai
commencé à tracer et faire en sorte
qu'on ait une alternance dans cette
région c'est possible avec 16,6 pour
cent des suffrages
le ministre et candidat modem la
république en marche se montrer tiers
ouvert à la discussion
faut qu'on essaie de trouver une
alternative et pesant que pour ceux là
l'heure est au rassemblement je n'ai
jamais dit que j'étais opposé au
rassemblement j'ai toujours pensé qu'à
un moment seul l'intérêt des habitants
la région sans compter l'intérêt des
habitants de la région centre c'est
qu'on ait une majorité qui ne soit pas
l'otage des plus radicaux de la gauche
résultat dans vos bureaux de vote
dimanche prochain il y aura bien quatre
candidatures nicolas forissier n'aurait
pas souhaité une fusion mais un retrait
de la liste macro nist marc fesneau a
refusé il va ainsi déposé sa propre
liste pour le second tour alors bruno
comment expliquer cette non fusion entre
la liste de marc fesneau et celle de
nicolas forissier pourtant elle était
attendue elle n'a pas lieu
alors d'abord elle rem un tract son
ancrage territorial ici en région centre
val de loire comme ailleurs dans les
autres régions oui parce que marc
fesneau et
soutient la liste rhin le candidat la
tête de liste de la liste la majorité
présidentielle voilà alors après qu'est
ce qui cloche entre nicolas forissier et
marc fesneau
on vient d'en entendre marc fesneau
était prêt à tendre la main
je crois que les états majors parisiens
en ont décidé autrement
la branche udi de marque de monsieur
forissier nicolas forissier était plutôt
favorable à un rapprochement
d'autres plus à droite notamment dans la
liste départementale en indre et loire
ont tenu bon elle n'était pas pour une
fusion en ont fait appel à l'arbitrage
de gérard larcher et de christian jacob
qui était présent la semaine dernière
dans ce département et ceux ci ont ont
dit non à écouter vous ne voulez pas la
fusion il y aura pas de fusion voilà
dire ça s'est passé et pas plus tard
qu'aujourd'hui et que ce matin donc
c'est vraiment très très récent on
développera tout ça dans les colonnes de
la nouvelle république droite a pris du
recul par rapport à cette dépendance
vis-à-vis de l air et les oem vous
regardez des résultats très décevants
voire mauvais derrière m
nicolas forissier l'avait dit en tout
début de campagne qu'il n'avait pas
besoin de marc fesneau
ensuite après c'est on ne connaît pas
tout alors est ce que marc fesneau se
maintiendra coûte que coûte au second
tour ça cette question c'est toute la
question tout le suspense je crois que
les candidats ont jusqu'à demain soir
pour déposer leurs 18 heures leur
candidature en préfecture de région à
orléans
d'ici là il peut se passer beaucoup de
choses